that is the big problem about just clove
sizes in america uh not not america like
it's just in japan
america's just in my head all constantly
i don't know in in she said that she
said this like it was pre-programmed
right she's american
yeah like uh especially shoe sizes shoe
sizes are like [ __ ] i can't buy shoes
yeah i don't [ __ ] involved into like
specialized store and just like pray
pray that they have the shoe size
i found the only i'm like the maximum
yeah the only store i've ever found in
japan that has shoes my size is the abc
modern shinjuku oh yeah that's like
which is where most of the foreigners
are but like you gotta go to where all
the foreigners are like i can't buy that
[ __ ] online i can't buy it like anywhere
outside of shinjuku
it's [ __ ] stupid like because there's
so many like amazing collabs as well
they're like the [ __ ] new balance
collab that they did with ava yeah was
so pissed off because they had like
these nice ava shoes and i was like oh
what size does it go up to it's like oh
26 i'm like you haven't eat 29 and a
half it's really small yeah 26 is tiny
no i i wish shirts and like shirts came
in like sizes like shoe sizes right no
i i i do because okay you get an s you
get an m you get an l logistical
nightmare what does that what does that
means different things depending on what
country you're in like okay well well we
should have i agree that we should have
some form of uniform rules on what s m l
is yeah but then i guess not every
country would agree because you know the
the normal in america is
totally different
japan i get an l in japan it's too small
like the first jojo suits i bought it
was an l right
and it was too small yeah right i get an
l in the uh in the us it's like three
sizes too big i'm just like what
like at least with shoe sizes it's a
number which i can correlate to
something yeah in with like shirt sizes
and suit sizes it's it's like a [ __ ]
free fall depending on what country
you're in and you and you have to hope
you have to hope that the store you're
buying from is a local japanese produced
store if you're buying american shirts
in a japanese store then you're still
[ __ ] because you're buying american
sizes so you've got to make sure but
shoes do the same thing you have uk
sizes you have u.s sizes you have jpg
but there is there is a conversion chart
for it so it's like all universal shoes
i've never had a problem with like i
know if they have it in my size when i'm
buying clothes in japan online it's a
[ __ ] model man i'm just like
is it the m or the l or is it the ll
[ __ ] i could be either one man it could
be no the worst the worst ones are the
ones that don't even use like s
they're the ones that use like one two
three four five and i'm like what does
that mean
what
what does that actually mean and i'm
just and they're just like oh we have
the convert we have the size conversion
chart on the website and i'm just like
who the [ __ ] uses a size conversion show
for t-shirts do you know a single person
who wants to buy a t-shirt and they're
just like all right let me get the tape
measure out all right yeah so what's the
shoulder width of an emphasize like i
hate the whole tall short nonsense with
coffee as well oh yeah yeah yeah like
tall is not the biggest one but it
sounds tall and grande is medium and
then what's the what's the big one
venting
what the [ __ ] does any of this [ __ ] mean
i get it i get it's italian right yeah
but like [ __ ] that yeah
just do small medium large extra lives
you know we we've had this like you know
we don't do some we don't do like
[ __ ] hot or cold in some other
language we just do hot occult and why
you know if the rules aren't uniform in
the coffee shop or whatever why are we
changing the [ __ ] rules
what's up with that
there's another site it's called trent
like when we you know when you pay you
don't pay in [ __ ] zero do you which
sounds fancy you know yeah it just
sounds fancy that's what i hate it's
like why are you turning like a uni an
agreed-upon standard into like your
[ __ ] passion project for your chain
you know what i mean i hate it that's
that's why until i got [ __ ] used to
the whole like especially starbucks
sizes because i never went to starbucks
in australia when the first time i went
to america and i was like oh yeah i'll
get the tall that's the biggest one
right i got this pissy little thing and
i was like all right next time i went i
was like uh biggest size please big size
big size so i i you know in the uk
sometimes i would order the venti size
because it was it was reasonably big
yeah
one time i made the mistake at anime
expo of ordering venti size and
starbucks in america yeah and i swear i
heard [ __ ] boss music playing when
they were like serving this [ __ ]
drink to me it took like four of them to
[ __ ] hold it up this massive fracking
market it was like one litre of ice
cream in this frappuccino i was like
[ __ ] hell how many calories is in
this i went online it was something like
2 100 calories in this frappuccino 2
100. holy [ __ ]
you haven't touched your bucket of ice
cream yet what's wrong if you haven't
touched your oreo baskin-robbins 2000
calorie milkshake it was insane how
could they serve this how is that legal
i don't know yeah
on the flip side though cough coffee
sizes in japan way too small oh my god
oh my god this is the biggest one this
is a large size this is a this is this
is a standard large size that you'd find
in any japanese coffee shop the biggest
they have like but here's the problem
right in japan sometimes this is
normally what i always want now this is
like the size that i've gotten
accustomed to and i actually quite like
it it's like a good amount yeah you feel
like i got a good milk to coffee ratio
yeah and now i always order the largest
thing they have because it's normally
like this yeah but then i get caught off
guard when you go to a place yeah and
you order the lodge and then it's like
oh [ __ ] it's actually lost yeah [ __ ] i
didn't expect this
like there's no i don't know i have no
idea what the lodge is some some coffee
shops mvps they have like a little
display that has the small medium and
large yeah display
what a nice mvp i can visualize how much
coffee or drink i'm going to receive oh
there are some places that like show you
how many milliliters it is right yeah
yeah yeah those ones are like nice it's
like going to an
american restaurant in japan and it's
just like well uh it's an american
restaurant so is it going to be american
sizes or is it going to be japanese
sizes because if it's going to be
japanese size i'm going to need to get
i'm going to need to order an appetizer
yeah if it's american sizes you don't
need to order that the appetizer is the
meal yeah yeah yeah bro yeah i ordered
[ __ ] nachos at the hard rock cafe
yeah the nachos was like my god you
could fit like four children on this
plate
it was insane and it was just my
appetizer i thought it was gonna be a
little bit i could at the nachos and
everyone at the table could have eaten
the nachos alone and we'd been full and
there's free refills in japan yeah in
japan oh yeah that's that's that's what
gets you right because you know you
expect japanese slices in japan but
whenever it's like american style you go
to some american-style restaurants and
they're still like japanese sizes you
know but you go to some american style
restaurants and they ain't playing
around they they're going all the way
they're all similar yeah yeah they're
they're fully assimilated to american
culture through and through
oh my god i can i can just like imagine
though like i mean we're already used to
all right imagine like just like an
innocent like japanese girl being like
oh i heard about this thing called hard
rock cucumber
i'm quite hungry let's get the biggest
a [ __ ] size
because it wasn't expensive either so
that's why i was kind of like
normally misleading normally like the
price to like if the appetizer is like
15 bucks yeah i'm like okay it's
probably gonna either be like really
high quality ingredients or something or
yeah pretty big and it's probably
normally pretty big yeah yeah and it was
massive it was gargantuan i could like
again i could hear the boss music like
[ __ ] zephyroth theme playing as they
were bringing it out
it was like that meme of like the other
chess grand master versus the kid like
in the russian tv show it was like that
it was like
i heard you wanted a large so we
prepared a bucket for you connor it was
like
a quick time event i'm gonna [ __ ] try
and do something to survive
yeah i just i just remember like the
first time i went to america it
completely blew my mind just like the
scale of the meals like i i just like i
wasn't prepared right because i had
always heard i think i've been smoking
about this before like right there's
never-ending stories about i mean
yeah because like i've heard about it
before but i don't think anything can
fully prepare you for the first time
that first plate gets put in front of
you and you just think
this is food that i need to consume like
i remember
i remember like the first time i went to
america it was like the first week um
and i i needed something that just
wasn't just greasy or you know wasn't
too filling because that that's awesome
you know by by that time i'd like eaten
like burgers and pizzas and [ __ ]
denny's whatever every day so i'm just
like i just want something healthy i
want something light i want a light
lunch um so we're at this diner an
oxymoron yeah yeah yeah yeah we're at
this this diner and i was like what's
the lightest thing they have well it's
possibly a salad right
there's no way you can make a salad not
anything but a light lunch yeah and i
was like i'm safe i'm safe i'll order
the salad and then i remember just
walking out and i see this [ __ ]
massive bowl in front of me and i'm just
like
who the [ __ ] deforested the amazon
rainforest and put it on my bowl like
how have americans found a way to make
salads unhealthy because like you they
[ __ ] drenched that [ __ ] interesting
right and i'm just like what
how i think if you want to go any
healthier than that you just have to
like get just a bucket of water
you can't get any healthier than that
say healthy what's that use of water